السياسه من ايران تحديدا حيث قال وزير
خارجيتها حسين امير عبد الحيان هنا بلاده
مستعده لاستئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه
واعاده فتح سفيرتي البلدين اذا ما كانت
الرياض مستعده لذلك واضاف عبد الاهيان في
مؤتمر صحفي هنا بلاده ترحب دائما بالحوار
والتعاون مع دول الجوار خاصه الدول
الخليجيه وفق تعبيره
بصوره طبيعيه واعاده فتح سفاره البلدين
اذا كانت الرياض مستعده لذلك وعلى الطرف
السعودي ان يقرر كيف يكون لديه موقف بناء
تجاه ايران مفاوضتنا مع السعوديه ستواصل
في اطارها السابق نعتقد ان قمه دول لجوار
العراق في الاردن قادره على ان تكون خطوه
الى الامام للخروج من التحديات التي
تشهدها المنطقه النتيجه النهائيه لهذه
القمه يجب ان تركز على التعاون الاقليمي
بعيدا عن التدخلات الاجنبيه ونرحب دائما
بالحوار والتعاون مع الدول الجوار خصوصا
الدول المطله على الخليج الفارسي
اردن
ودفهامات الموجهه لصهران بشان تسليم
المسيرات لروسيا باطله واضاف خلال كلمته
في منتدى حوار طهران ان الدول الغربيه
تسعى لتبرير دعمها للحرب في اوكرانيا عبر
توجيه مثل تلك الاتهامات لطهران حسب
تعبيره
منذ البدايه اكدنا على رفضنا للعنف وضروره
تسويه الازمه عبر الحلول السياسيه واتخذنا
موقفا محيدا واكدنا ان القلق الامنيه
الموجوده عند الطرفين يجب ان يؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار وتتم تسميته عبر الحوار من جهه
اخرى نؤمن بضروره وجود نظره شامله لهذه
الازمه الاتهامات مواجهه ضدنا فيما يتعلق
بارسال التجهيزات والمسيرات لروسيا باطله
ولا اسس لها والدول الغربيه تسعى الى
تبريد دعم هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا عبر
توجيه هذه الاتهامات لايران